it seems like in Austin there's a lot of
camaraderie between the comics and you
guys have each other's back and it's
kind of like I guess a boy club I don't
there might be females in it but that
you guys have each other's back and
support each other yeah no yeah and
there's the some of the strongest
females we got Roseanne Bar to move here
who lives 30 minutes away and her
standup when she's in the zone there's
nobody stronger when she when the when
the when the lithium and the monat or
whatever she's on
is it is it the perfect crisp there's
literally not a strong you know what is
no I'm just kidding it's for yeast
infections well yes whatever whatever
the different things that she's on at
any she got her yeast under control yeah
she's good who knows what kind of
cocktail that L's on at any given point
right but if she's in the right the
absolute right place half a scotch h a
quarter of a blond whatever it takes cuz
she's you know she's a she's a chemical
anomaly right and but I mean literally
she just hits a Groove and there's no
one cooler no one funnier and there's
her Whitney comes all the time and we
have a bunch of uh you know fantastic
people in the um you know the farm
system coming up as door guys and door
girls and I there no competitiveness
amongst anyone that you've seen oh well
it's all we're all trying to you know
everybody's trying to be the best but
you know what but it would there there
seems to be and and I agree with her
there seems to be and I love it more
camaraderie more um sharing it's it's
also by virtue of what the culture is
and even in music you know when when I
was coming up you know on in music you
would buy somebody's album now when you
listen to Somebody's song There's
featured acts by the same
token
there is like headliner by beside
headliner beside headliner that wasn't
done but I think that's the it's also
part of Rogan's mentality I mean he's
really the one he started this where he
would take the most intense killers and
put them right in front of him Joey Diaz
uh when I started working uh with Joe it
was Joey Diaz and Ari shaffir who were I
mean and are freaks the last things
pretty much you want to go up after are
these guys smashing just filthy and
aggressive comedy to where your mind is
just blown and Joe's thing is blow their
minds give them their money worth before
you even hit the stage and then you have
to follow it so you're getting better
even though it's your show the trick the
thing that we talk about a lot I think a
trap that a lot of successful really
successful stand-ups get in is they want
to be the star of their show they want
to be the best person you but they paid
for a ticket for me I'm not going to
bury myself and meanwhile you can have
it all you can grow while thriving you
know so well that's a different I think
that's what you were alluding to that's
a very different philosophy than the
than in the 70s but and I think that
philosophy you know bleeds onto uh you
know music yeah and you know it's all of
us when I do my uh theater tour that I'm
doing right now um and they have no idea
who's going to come who's going to come
out and be on the show but the first
thing that they see if he if it's
available is William Montgomery comes
out and does 15 minutes your closer
which to them ton so like to them it's
like going to a Lauren Michaels show and
seeing Chris Farley or going to a Vince
McMahon show and seeing Hulk Hogan first
you know and then again this is actually
a philosophy that I learned from Vince
McMahon is cu he would start Monday
Night Raw or pay-per-views with a bang
you wouldn't know the order of events
but it would surprise you the start
you'd be like wow why is the guy that I
was thinking was going to headline this
thing or Main event be why is he coming
out now here we go the show is started
so like I really believe in that like
starting things with a bang and like you
know he kills so hard these people watch
William every single week for over five
years doing a minute of standup
independently and then an8 minute
interview of just chaos he's being
hilarious and people get famous off of
what doing one hour special once every
three or five years and here he is doing
8 minutes a week week 8 minutes times 52
so that's basically like eight 1 hour
specials per year and I mean it's they
they're so connected to him that he can
do anything not to mention his best
possible set that we're constantly
talking about and thinking about how to
make it better how to move this around
or this or that because we talk about it
a lot I like to run you know kill Tony
kind of like a college football program
you know growth is kind of as corny as
this sounds and I know here we are
talking about com and the numbers and
this and that but it's like you know I
really believe in making things even
better how do we yes we destroyed oh my
God everybody was so happy best show
ever blah blah blah but how do we make
it a little bit
better